I think in the venture capital space
Founders Fund came out of nowhere and
became in under a decade what people
consider you know top five I think would
be a fair assessment where would you
where are you guys in terms of I think
why if you if you do buy the scoreboard
and buy returns really top three top
three yeah top is fine I'll take that
okay so I'll just I'll give you four top
fourth I will split the difference but
if you look at the at the portfolio over
here let's go from left to right at the
top this one stem Centrex nobody heard
of you invested in a cancer company and
it got sold for how much over what
period of time
well we invested in early 2012 in some
Centrex it's a therapeutic biotech
company focusing on carrying cancer it
got bought for ten point two billion by
Alvey last year and so this is quite a
return I don't know what those return
numbers mean over there I think the top
this was supposed to be an angel
investing conference and you have too
much angel investing but I think the top
one is like return on first investment
and the bottom one is blended return
overall investments in the company and
you're placing huge bets yes what was
the bed in some stem Centrex and what
percentage of the fun yeah it wasn't
thank you for putting it like that that
is the actual correct way to put it
percent of funds like yeah so the we put
we made a six our first investment in
stem Centrex the one in 2012 is a six
percent of fund investments that's a the
the the fun for made the investment
eccentric 625 million dollar fine put
about thirty five million in on that
first check and then piled on to the
point of eventually putting about three
hundred million dollars into the company
and so while the return of the twenty
four x in the early fund on a percentage
basis was just in a return is just
extraordinary on a pure dollar basis the
five point seven returned the blended
return or the latest return
Shawn cash was much greater yeah we cows
on cash is so explain that yeah let's
break in that example oh I should about
300 million dollars in de-stem Centrex
and you can multiply it by that bottom
number and that's the Katan so that you
can figure out the cash on cash there
which is also the right metric to
discuss when discussing venture capital
it's not about deal based IRR I mean
that's kind of irrelevant like it's
perhaps when cash number so let's talk a
little bit about SpaceX that's another
one that's worked out pretty well for
you tell us about your history and
SpaceX yeah so actually the SpaceX
investment was the reason why I joined
founders fund so I was doing a bunch of
angel investing and had my own angel
fund and then in late 2007 I met Sean
Parker who I became friends with and I
was about to raise another angel fund
raised you know just a personal money an
angel fund and he said oh why don't you
come check out what we're doing at
founders fun tonight of course I never
heard of founders fund in late 2007 but
I went down there and that's when they
were considering investing in this
company called SpaceX and I said oh this
is exactly what I want to do and and so
we made our first SpaceX investment in
2008 we our first investment in SpaceX
was a 11% of fund investment which you
know not many venture capital firms are
set up to do these types of bets but
this is how you make money in venture
capital like you're not going to make
money by doing 2% bets you know all day
and so the first investment in SpaceX
was an 11% to fund investment and you
know we we've since put about 200
million dollars into SpaceX total and
still investing in SpaceX and of course
Palantir Peter tal who founded founders
fund with Sean Parker it was the two of
them can Kenny and Luke and Kenny were
involved as well they were the first
four and they brought you in that's
right
but Palantir was something that Peter
had started as well and that's done it
pretty pretty well as well talk about
Palantir and tell us a little bit about
what Palantir does No yeah I mean
volunteers you're it's like we like to
say we don't have to hear pitches from a
lot of these big data companies because
we have the big data company in Palantir
Palantir fine that's terrifying continue
volunteer has you know Khan has
relationships and clients ranging from
governments to commercial entities
looking for you know patterns and
they've actually done some pretty
amazing things especially things that
people in this room can really
appreciate that we can't really talk
about but yeah Palantir we actually
detecting us against another 9/11 would
be one of them maybe and we've made we
one of our Palantir investments was a
33% of fund investment so just to give
some context we put about 75 million of
a 240 million dollar fund into Palantir
at a billion dollar valuation and of
course deepmind was the 30 or 40 PhDs in
England who figured out how to make a
clock understand it was a clock indeed I
remember meeting the founder at one of
these parties and it was 2:00 in the
morning and he's like yeah and then the
clock realized it was a clock and I was
like can use five years ago he's playing
that to me and he said well the clock we
bought the clock and then it figured out
it was on a network and then I tried to
leave the network and I was like wow
this kids really drunk or no no full of
[ __ ] and then they got WAP I explained
what deepmind did that got them bought
by Google and when you met them and what
was going on over there because there is
no deepmind product in the world that's
right and so define of all the companies
on this is the one on there that doesn't
actually have a product and it was an
interesting investment because the the
team was above and beyond anything we'd
ever seen we actually did the seed
investment in deepmind so we are
completely stage agnostic and completely
sector agnostic will write checks from
you know 100k to 300 million
and deepmind was just a PhD project
these were just the smartest people and
artificial intelligence we had ever met
and when it came but they had no ideas
for what they were going to do to
productize this how did you find them
they reached out to you are they ring
yeah Oxford know through connections you
do work is ventricle you go and meet
people yeah I mean audiences and
somebody said smart people are people
and sometimes you make connections and
they're like oh you're into that okay
remember this is in 2010 this is pre
before a I was as Esther pointed out
this you know ubiquitous thing all
around especially in the investment
community and there weren't many people
who are willing to invest in a company
that had no absolutely no vision of what
their product would be other than they
were going to actually get to artificial
general intelligence first and so we saw
a lot of value in that but then yes they
eventually Larry Page could offer them a
much bigger budget than any venture
capitalist and this was disappointing to
you I'm taking it because this company's
sold with 30 or 40 employees from what I
understand and had unlimited upside and
you all tried to stop them from taking
Larry Page as monies well what I'll
never try and necessarily stop a founder
from doing anything convince them to
stay independent was what we tried
giving them options to stay independent
you know and then at the end they do
that time I take me through that to
school it needs it needs money right
there cut the founder needs money and
the banner needs to be able to like say
like okay if I take this money I'm still
not going to build a product that
generates any money for another 20 years
so you guys really want to do that right
and with 20 years you're being facetious
they had an idea of a product in year 21
something like that they're gonna build
artificial general intelligence general
artificial intelligence not narrow not
specific I'm not gonna go they're not
gonna wing that the goal of this company
is not to win go like they've been doing
now yeah yeah but now they're trying to
win go or they're doing the go project
where they do it all the way it's all
the way they are the Larry Page is
giving them a pretty big budget to do
this